après cette vidéo ça va être le moment
de partir en vacances de faire une
petite pause de youtube mais avant tout
ça il faut vraiment qu'on parle de ces
choses qui vous empêche de vous lancer
dans la vidéo que ce soit sur youtube ou
en pro ou deux voilà de prendre votre
caméra et d'y aller et tout ça on va en
parler
juste après l'intro
[Musique]
et salut à tous les amis c'est françois
pour la chaîne explique mme encore je
suis ravi de vous retrouver sur cette
chaîne où on parle de vidéos on parle de
matos on parle de création parle de
créativité on parle de plein plein plein
de trucs de montage tout ça donc si
c'est quelque chose qui vous plaît
pensez pas à vous abonner parce que même
si là on va faire une petite pause d'été
un la pause traditionnelle de l'été à la
rentrée je vous ferai part des trucs de
fou je vous en dirai un petit peu plus
en fin de vidéo
aujourd'hui on va donc parler de ces
choses qui vous empêche de vous lancer
qui font que vous regardez des vidéos
vous regarder des trucs vous essayé mais
n'était pas encore prêt vous sentez pas
voilà est-ce que vraiment je saute
dedans est ce que je lance ma chaîne
youtube est ce que je montre mon
auto-entreprise et puis que je commence
à me faire payer voilà tout ce qui vous
bloque un petit peu on en parle et je
vais vous donner plein d'astuces et
plein de réponses pour que ça se passe
bien et c'est normal d'avoir la trouille
c'est normal que ça fasse peur c'est un
sacré pas et si vous arrivez à le
franchir déjà bravo parce que c'est
vraiment pas évident c'est vraiment pas
facile donc vous pourrez vous dire quand
vous serez lancé déjà
je les fais une ça y est je me
suis je me suis challenge est donc si
après cette vidéo tu décides de te
lancer un énorme bravo à toi qui regarde
cette vidéo
le premier gros freins le truc qui fout
la trouille et qui pourtant vraiment la
base c'est tout simplement de se dire
oui mais j'ai jamais fait je ne me sens
pas légitime
comment je pourrais y arriver je sais
pas faire et ça c'est le principe de
tous les trucs nouveaux tout ce que vous
allez tenter tout ce qui va être hors de
votre zone de confort forcément ça fait
peur et c'est un sacré pas à faire que
ce soit encore une fois de se lancer sur
youtube de se mettre devant une caméra
et de lui parler ou d'aller voir des
gens et de leur dire bonjour je fais de
la vidéo et je peux vous vendre mes
services dites vous qu on est tous
passés par là
on a tous eu une première fois on était
tous morts de trouille et il ya plein de
façons de commencer en douceur commencé
peut-être par aller travailler avec
quelqu'un qui fait des vidéos allait
proposer d'être second twitter sur un
tournage d'assister un ami à vous qui
fait des vidéos sur youtube pour voir un
petit peu comment ça se passe si
vraiment vous vous sentez pas d'y aller
directement tout seul n'hésitez pas à
vous entourer et à ne pas faire ça tout
seul le fait de ne jamais l'avoir fait
ne veut pas dire que vous n'en êtes pas
capables
et si vous le faites pas vous ne saurez
jamais
vous en êtes capable ou pas donc un
moment donné il faut se dire ok on va
tester
pourquoi pas qu'est ce que je risque au
pire qu'est ce qui peut se passer
allons-y essayons et surtout faites de
votre mieux et donnez vous à fond même
si le résultat des premières fois sera
forcément va foufou par rapport à ce que
vous serez capable de faire plus tard le
deuxième point que j'entends souvent
aussi c j'ai pas fait d'études dans ce
domaine là je suis pas légitime à faire
des vidéos où aller vendre ou à donner
des conseils sur youtube ou à me mettre
sur youtube pourquoi est ce que les gens
me regarderai où pourquoi est ce que les
gens achèteraient mes vidéos alors pour
les études
rassurez vous on est énormément dans ce
cas à être des autodidactes à moi je
j'étais prof rien à voir je me suis
formé tout seul
j'ai discuté avec des gens j'ai appris
avec d'autres vidéaste j'ai écouté les
conseils comme données et finalement
j'ai réussi à en faire mon métier
alors je dis pas que ça peut marcher
pour tout le monde bien entendu mais
dans la vidéo ou dans l'art de manière
générale les études ça peut être un plus
ça peut être très bien a refait un bts
audiovisuel par exemple mais rien ne
remplacera jamais l'expérience que vous
aurez et la manipulation et le fait de
faire des vidéos vous pouvez apprendre
tout autant en sortant et en faisant
plein de vidéos que avec un cursus
d'études ça vous rendra pas moins
légitime puisque basque on regardera au
final c'est pas vos diplômes c'est les
vidéos que vous faites si vos vidéos
elle déchire si vous si vous cartonnez
dans ce que vous faites il ya personne
qui va allez vous demander
excuse moi tu as fait quoi comme études
pour faire cette vidéo là non parce que
si t'as pas fait d'études la vidéo elle
est pourrie la qualité de la vidéo ne ne
sera pas jugé par rapport à votre cursus
et je ne dis pas non plus que les études
d'audiovisuel ne servent à rien c'est
pas ça que je dis je dis juste que c'est
pas un passage obligé
l'autre point que j'entends aussi et ça
ça concerne surtout les gens qui veulent
devenir vidéaste professionnelle et qui
veulent vendre de la vidéo c'est j'ai
pas de clients comment je peux faire je
vais pas me lancer j'ai pas de clients
alors j'ai fait une vidéo détaillé qui
s'affiche quelque part par ici pour vous
expliquer un petit peu comment vivre de
vos vidéos
mais de manière générale il vaut mieux
se lancer quand on a quand même quelques
pistes
un soin fait une étude de marché soit on
a déjà des gens qui nous demandent est
ce que tu pourrais me faire une vidéo
par ci par là à voir quand même une base
est pas non plus sauter complètement
dans l'inconnu en disant j'ai zéro
client
mais on peut aussi aller directement
toquer aux portes et faire des essais
avant de se lancer complètement
rien ne vous empêche de faire ça les
week-ends ou alors à mi temps et puis
progressivement de passer sur du plein
temps les clients
ça viendra à force aussi de faire des
vidéos plus vous en faites plus vous
êtes visible plus vous êtes visible plus
potentiellement vous avez touché deux
futurs clients donc c'est sûr que ne pas
se lancer dans le sens ne pas se jeter à
l'eau et essayer ça freine tout de suite
l'arrivée des clients en plus vous en
ferez plus vous en aurez est ici vous en
faites pas vous en aurez pas c'est pas
plus compliqué que ça après c'est sûr
que avoir une clientèle fidèle et
suffisamment de clients c'est une autre
affaire mais dans tous les cas sans se
lancer
il y en aura pas ensuite vient le
traditionnel oui mais j'ai pas de matos
j'ai pas un stabilisateur j'ai pas un
atome os j'ai pas des optiques signer
j'ai pas d light j'ai pas machin alors
franchement moi je me dis qu'au final
quand je pars en resta avec tout le
matos que j'ai et je pense que je vais
en revendre une partie je me dis que je
suis sûr équipé parce que au final on
n'a pas besoin d'énormément de matériel
un petit boîtier avec une optique sympa
pour pas très cher un petit enregistreur
sonore pour faire quand même des
captations de son éventuellement une
petite lumière d'appoint ou des petites
choses comme ça ça va pas chercher très
loin
moi quand j'ai démarré j'avais beaucoup
moins de matériel que maintenant et
j'arrivais quand même à trouver des
plantes ce qui va faire la différence
c'est pas votre matos c'est ce que vous
allez en faire c'est les histoires que
vous allez raconter c'est la qualité et
le sérieux de votre travail c'est pas
votre matériel n'attendez pas d'avoir
une raide pour vous lancer dans la vidéo
ça n'aurait aucun sens quand on voit ce
que les boîtiers mirrorless sont
capables de faire maintenant qu'elles
soient du z6 que ce soit du gh5 que ce
soit même les séries à 6000 de sony il
ya moyen de faire des choses très très
très très jolie et très qualitative sans
avoir un énorme matériel bon après on va
pas non plus se pointer avec un
smartphone ça ferait un petit peu moyen
sauf si on fait vraiment du contenu
réseaux sociaux des trucs très très
court et très ponctuel ça peut tout à
fait servir de caméras d'appoint mais si
on veut être un petit peu pris au
sérieux il vaut mieux quand même avoir
un petit boîtier je vous mets des liens
dans la description de petits boîtiers
pas cher que je trouve vraiment très
très intéressant et enfin la plus grosse
question celle qui est je suis sur le
plus gros frein au fait que vous vous
lanciez ou pas c'est la fameuse question
et si jamais ça marche pas alors ça
c'est une question qui est très
intéressante et que je pense tout le
monde se pose moi c'est une question qui
m'a un petit peu bloqué qui me faisait
un peu peur et si ça marche pas qu'est
ce que je vais faire
du coup ce que j'ai fait et ça ça
n'engage que moi c'est que j'y suis allé
par paliers certes je ne suis pas lancé
d'un coup d'un seul en me disant voilà
de but en blanc aujourd'hui je quitte
tout et je fais juste de la vidéo et ça
va marcher maintenant il faut pas non
plus se mettre des oeillères il faut
quand même être réaliste ça peut
potentiellement ne pas marcher l'idée
c'est de se prévoir tout un tas de plan
b est de ne pas se lancer donc d'y aller
progressivement un pas après l'autre
parce que comme je vous disais en fait
le client appelle le client plus vous
ferez de vidéos plus on vous sollicitera
parce qu'on vous connaîtra c'est sûr
qu'au début il faut pas non plus tabler
sur une réussite extraordinaire dès le
départ mais progressivement votre carnet
d adresses il va s'étoffer
progressivement vous allez être connus
localement les gens se diront ah oui
c'est vrai j'ai besoin de vidéo je sais
qu'il ya telle personne qui en fait
elles sont chouettes j'aime bien je vais
le contacter et qu'est ce qui peut se
passer au pire ça ne marche pas si vous
avez
prévu le coup si vous n'êtes pas lancer
tête baissée et ben ça aura juste pas
marché cette fois peut-être que la
prochaine fois ça marchera peut-être que
vous tenterez autre chose que ça bien en
tous les cas si vous avez fait les
choses intelligemment vous en sortirez
ni blessé ni ruiner peut-être vous serez
un petit peu blessé dans votre
amour-propre nous dire voilà bon mais je
me suis trompé mais spoiler alert
on a tous des échecs on se plante tous
dans certains trucs à certains moments
ça n'existe pas les gens qui réussissent
tout d'un coup et kiki voilà par magie
tout ce qu'ils font ça se transforme en
or et ça fonctionne plein de gens que
vous regardez que vous admirez vous
connaissez se sont plantés avant de
réussir et c'est un petit peu la base je
pense que pour réussir dans tous les cas
si on ne s'est pas planté avant c'est
pas c'est pas possible quoi ils peuvent
donc pas à prendre sans se tromper donc
pour répondre à cette question si jamais
ça marche pas à ben ça marche pas ça
marche pas et est-ce que c'est grave
absolument pas et d'ailleurs si vous
êtes d'accord avec ça vous pouvez mettre
le traditionnel coup de blaster sur le
pouce en l'air qui se situe juste en
dessous de cette vidéo
et puis les amis je vous dis un grand
merci pour cette saison qui s'achève
on va partir un petit peu tous en
vacances fin c'est pas des vraies
vacances parce qu'il ya plein de boulot
tout ça mais voilà petites vacances de
youtube on va se retrouver un petit peu
avant la rentrée je pense qu'on va se
retrouver fin août il y aura peut-être
quelques petites vidéos qui sortiront
dans le courant de l'été et j'aurais
sûrement de trucs vous partagez mais le
rythme habituel reprendra à la fin août
en attendant n'hésitez pas à venir sur
le disque ornent également à vous
inscrire pour l'élève qui auront aussi
lieu à la rentrée où on analyse vos
chaînes en direct sur twitter pouvez
aussi me suivre sur un stage mettrait
des story pendant l'été je vous dis
encore un immense merci les amis en
cette année ça a été ça a été assez ou
feint la barre des 50 mille abonnés a
été passé je sais pas du tout où on va
s'arrêter mais ça c'est grâce mais
encore une fois un rester curieux et moi
je vous donne rendez vous très très très
bientôt pour de nouvelles aventures pour
plein de nouvelles vidéos à très bientôt
les amis chaud